a ver vamos a ver si podemos escribir el
número 0.15 o sea punto 15 como una
fracción y bueno el principal truco aquí
es ver en qué posición están estos
dígitos o sea por ejemplo el 1 está en
un lugar de las décimas y entonces lo
que representa es tomar este 1 y
multiplicarlo por un décimo o sea 1
entre 10 y por ejemplo este 5 como está
en el lugar de las centésimas lo que
significa es que multiplicamos el 5 por
una centésima o sea por 1 entre sí
ok y finalmente pues todo esto lo que es
es la suma de estas multiplicaciones o
sea aquí lo que tenemos es la suma de
uno por un décimo más
5 por una centésima y eso al fin y al
cabo lo podemos escribir así o sea el 1
por un décimo se ve así no y el 5 por
una centésima se ve así
ahora a la hora de sumar estos dos
números lo que tenemos que hacer es
buscar un denominador común y pues ese
denominador común va a ser 100 no
entonces aquí tenemos centésimas
otras centésimas ahora para pasar de
este denominado a este denominador nada
más multiplicamos por 1 entonces este 5
lo tenemos que multiplicar por 1 y nada
más se va a quedar así
en cambio de este lado para que este
denominador se asiente tuvimos que
multiplicarlo por 10 ok entonces para
pasar de aquí a acá tenemos que
multiplicar por 10 y entonces el
numerador también lo tenemos que
multiplicar por 10 y 1 por 10 pues es 10
y bueno 10 centésimas más 5 centésimas
que es igual pues el denominador va a
seguir siendo el mismo
y el numerador va a ser 10 + 5 o sea 15
ok entonces punto 15 es igual a 15 en
300 y ahora pues nada más tenemos que
simplificar esta fracción los dos
números son divisibles entre 5 no
entonces pues dividamos lo entre 5
35 porque me da 15 5 por 3 me da 15 y 5
porque me da 100 pues 5 por 20 me da 100
y estos 25 se cancelan y finalmente nos
queda
veinteavos entonces 0.15 es igual a 320
a vos